[Musique]
j'ai pris la route de Dijon pour voir un
peu la margeolaine la belle dig digedon
qui pleurait près de la fontaine mais
elle avait changé le ton il lui fallait
déducaton dedans son bas de laine pour
n'avoir plus de peine elle m'a dit tu
viens chérie et si tu me payes un bon
prix aux anges je t'emmène dig dig don
la Marjoline pleurait
surtout quand elle n'avait pas de
s la Marjolain de la
chanson avait de plus nobles
façons j'ai passé le pont d'Avignon pour
voir un peu les bellesdames et les beaux
messieurs tous en rond qui dansaient
dans ses corps et âmes mais ils avaient
changé de ton il faisait FID des
rigodons menu et épavanes tarantelle
sardane et les belles dames mon dit ceci
étranger sauv-toi d'ici où l'on donne
l'alarme aux chiens et aux gendarmes
quelle mouche les a donc
piqué ces bellesdames si
distinguées les belles-dames de la
chanson avait de plus nobles
façons je me suis fait faire prisonnier
dans les vieilles prisons de Nantes pour
voir la fille du jolier qui paraî-il est
à Nant mais elle avait changé de ton
quand j'ai demandé que diton des
affaires courantes dans la ville de
Nantes la mignonne m'a répondu on dit
que vous serez pendu au matine sonnante
et j'en suis bien contente les jolières
n'ont plus de cœur au prisons de nanté
d'ailleurs la jolière de la
chanson avait de plus nobles
façon vous l'emmener à bonne fin ma
folle course vagabonde vers mes pénates
je revins pour dormir auprès de ma
blonde mais elle avait changé de ton
avec elle sous les dredon il y avait du
monde dormant près de ma blonde j'ai
pris le coup d'un a blagueur mais en
cachette dans mon cœur la peine était
profonde le chagrin lâch la bonde hélas
du jardin de mon
père la colombe s'est fait la
PA par bonheur par
consolation me sont resté les qure
chansons